this is not going to be very
lengthy is it because no this is not
going to be easy or lengthy
you know yeah that first yeah i got you
i'm with you so lima and larry yeah
we have some i don't even know what kind
of news this is
what what happened last last mother's
day right just
yeah on mother's day so um on
sunday may 9th um
the treatment center staff walked into
amanda's room thinking that she was just
peacefully sleeping
and realized that she had passed away
um it's been a really
really big shock for us
and my brain hasn't really been able to
comprehend it
um and announcing it makes it real so
it's hard to believe it's very hard to
believe
and so i think
they well i know that they did an um a
toxicology report
all she had in her system was tylenol
she was i was actually supposed to fly
in
for her transfer to outpatient care
and she never got transferred so
she remained at residential care so she
had 24
7 supervision any
foul play any self-harm anything
in that nature was already rolled out so
she died
of physical natural causes
and so i think it's really important to
note for everybody watching
that mental health sorry
mental health can cause physical illness
and um the time that amanda spent on the
street
is the reason that she passed away so
the amount of time
the amount of traumatic brain injury
that she endured
we were working on rep repairing her jaw
because
she was brutally beaten and raped so
severely on multiple occasions and three
that
larry shared with me but there was many
more that we don't even know about
so um all of that damage to her brain
the physical damage aside from the
mental illness
um the abuse that she did with crack
cocaine
which was very severe um the way
the fact that she was a little heavier
before she had ever used
drugs and i actually have a photo of
amanda on my instagram page with larry
who um where this was before she had
ever touched any substance
and she was a little heavier and so when
she started using
crack we watched on your channel that
she just
withered away and when i got her into my
care
i could literally wrap my fingers
completely around her wrist
so she was she went from being heavier
to
anorexic when we got her into the
treatment center her physical condition
was so
deteriorated she had such a
so much malnutrition and a lot of times
when someone's been clean for a while
they end up overeating because to make
up for that calorie deficit so the
people who are underweight require
about three thousand to five thousand
calories
um just to get back to zero but that
also
[Music]
that doesn't include the damage that's
been done to the metabolism
and to the body and the digestion so
um in my opinion
and we're still waiting for the autos
autopsy report that's going to take
about
two to three months they told us but
amanda was just homeless too long
sorry but
so i think that she proved
that there's no such thing
as impossible when it comes to her
mental health care all of the people
that said she couldn't be helped
everybody that said that there was
nothing that could be done
to save her she proved everybody wrong
and um we had so many plans we made that
video of like what it's like to go to
treatment
there was a bunch of other videos that
amanda wanted to make with me
um and she had so many things that she
was so
motivated by and that's another thing
um that people don't understand is when
you have someone that's homeless
and when you have someone even if
they're not homeless and they're abusing
drugs
it destroys your prefrontal cortex which
is in the front of your brain
and what that part is responsible for is
planning it's responsible for impulse
control it's responsible for
any type of empathy
and so when you're telling someone you
need to go to
rehab you need to go to treatment if you
look at and i encourage
everybody that watches these videos to
just
google spect imaging brain spect imaging
and look at what
a healthy brain looks like and what a
brain looks like when you have a drug
addiction or alcohol addiction
and what that what those scans show
is brain activity and blood flow
and so you're going to see that the
brain of someone who's using a substance
looks like swiss cheese so it has a
bunch of holes in it
those holes are not real holes in your
brain
they're just where blood does not flow
so it's really important to not just
um expect those people to make their own
decisions so by allowing people to be
homeless and abuse themselves and hurt
themselves
and end up in such physical pain
and when amanda when the blood flow in
amanda's brain returned
and when she had been sober for almost
two
200 over 200 days
and she was watching her videos from
back then and
and she called me and told me i never
want to go back to that life
i can't believe that was me she called
me in tears crying
watching those videos back and she was
showing the
she wasn't even embarrassed about it she
was proud of how far she'd come
that she was showing the other patients
at the treatment center that wanted to
leave against medical advice they just
wanted to leave early in relapse
she was showing them her videos and
saying you don't want to end up like
this
and she was actually convincing patients
to stay in treatment
so yeah her story is very encouraging
for anybody who
is fighting addiction or has a family
member fighting addiction
larry you called me sunday morning
to tell me the news it was unbelievable
yes
because see i have been speaking with
the man there more frequently the last
week or so
we exchange photos each day just as a
way of staying connected
so she had talked to me quite late
actually on saturday evening they had
karaoke
they had pizza i think they're outside
eating so
outside was her favorite spot where
she'd go and smoke her cigarettes and
watch the volleyball
so she always described the space was
her little heel
and when i got there to see it it was so
vivid
from her description until i could just
feel her presence
yeah the um the staff
the amanda touched so many lives there
because
number one she was there for a while so
the staff really got to know her and
they actually
they were so devastated that they had to
not only bring grief counselors for the
patients
but also grief counselors for the staff
and the patients came up with an idea
where
they wanted to host their own little
memorial for her
so they made this big butterfly and they
hung it on a tree and they made all of
these flowers and put them on this tree
for amanda
and they painted a bunch of rocks and
made a little memorial for her
at group therapy
there was a chair that amanda always sat
in
and um
all of the patients picked a flower and
they put a flower on her chair
and um a patient thought was new there
that didn't know amanda went to sit in
the chair and a fight broke out so
so so i mean the autopsy is still in
progress
yeah your but it was a physical issue
that was caused
by um either the brain
the something in what what their what
their
what they're saying which i don't have
all of the details because they're still
investigating
is that it was caused by either the
abuse that she took from the rapes so
the violence
and it could have also played a role
with the extent
of the drug abuse that she had done
prior
um so it was a physical problem that was
caused by
mental illness a blood clot aneurysm
something like that
yeah and so we're we're gonna um
you know we'll definitely follow up and
share once we have that information
um but larry did you
did you have anything that you wanted to
specifically address
uh i i wanted you to know that
your help was immeasurable thank you
because
mark and i was out here just trying our
best on a day-to-day basis
and we were just spinning our wheels
actually and we were always hoping for a
miracle
mark would say just plain as day and
then i would say
maybe maybe today but i'd go out there
we'd get busy trying to do something
so when i met lima it was just
a change in my life and then since
amanda been
off the streets in the best of care
she would tell me amanda would call me
and tell me i didn't have to go over
there she described all of the
the process and the services and the
people so she was very happy
i remember when i noticed a big change
in amanda because
um she called me and i was worried
because you know i'm like oh my god she
wants to leave or
she doesn't like something or she needs
something so
i saw her i saw her number on my phone
and my heart sank into my stomach and
i'm like oh did something happen and she
called me and she was like
um hey lima and i'm like hey what's up
and she's like
nothing i just wanted to call and say i
love you
and i was just started crying on the
phone because i was not expecting that
and um she's like i just wanted to check
on you
and i hope that you don't mind but i
didn't have my mom growing up and you're
kind of like
me so what has happened is
and then she died on mother's day may i
say amanda wrote a letter to her mother
last week
oh she did now her therapist told me
this when i was there
so it's somewhere in her belongings that
i need to find
and she wants me to read it first
yeah so amanda had a lot of
conflict with her mom and she shared
with me that
her mom was never really there for her
and when she was staying with her mom
she was always taking care of her
brother and i guess her mom abused drugs
and really neglecting her and her
brother
and she blamed her mom for her brother
being autistic and using drugs while she
was pregnant with her brother
um and so she had a lot of anger towards
her
so her therapist had encouraged her to
she encouraged her to write a letter to
her mom
and it was really incredible because
amanda i spoke to her right before she
went to sleep before she passed and
she had so much closure and she
she when i first met her she had no
self-worth at all
and by the end she was so proud of
herself
and she she had so much closure with her
mom and she was actually making
plans to reach out to her birth mother
and read the letter to her
[Music]
and i just think that that was that was
pretty incredible because when she died
she died beautiful she died totally
clean
she had inspired so many people and
um she
and she died in peace like she didn't
have anything hanging over her where she
i think the most incredible part of
amanda's story is how
like in the last three four months she
just
you saw her progress progressively
awesome she's awesome
you're in the prayer doing the the
individual counseling for new
news news students yeah she was so and
she was doing so many things
i could never imagine she wanted to be
helpful
yeah she was so inspired by the stuff
that helped her that
she wanted to be a certified medical
assistant and so
she just started her um like we got her
the study guide and she just
she was supposed to start her online
schooling and um
she was looking for i asked her once she
steps down to outpatient she's going to
be staying at a sober living
but once she's staying at a sober living
we're going to be job training her
helping her back
go back to school that was part of the
scholarship we were offering
with our donors and so
i asked her if she'd like to be in a
sober living or how she'd like to do
that
longer term and she said that she want
her goal was to get her dad off
of skin row because he lives in va
housing on skin row
and and she wanted to go to school in
orange county
and just find a college that had the
program so i promised her that we would
get larry off skid row and
i'm going to continue to keep my promise
i mean i think the most important thing
to take away from this
whole story from start to finish yeah
how much is possible how much is
possible but
how much damage is being done every
single day
when you allow people to put a tent up
and kill themselves and when we don't
talk about is how many dead people there
are in all of these tents that you see
everywhere
because people overdose and they die and
no one goes in the tents
and um that's so inhumane
so i had a lot of pushback when i was
hold on
forcing amanda to go to treatment but
again
amanda could not make her own decision
that was the only way because amanda was
ever gonna get better
was forcing her yeah but those but
people who
who have that much damage to their brain
from drug use and also the trauma that
she suffered like
dying in dignity does not mean let her
go be free she's an
adult that the amount of damage she took
to just her skull and her jaw and all
the lost
teeth that she lost um
is it's just unbelievable that that
our system would consider letting you
put a tent
up as humane and that it's okay i feel
like
there should be a lot done to change the
homelessness situation and offer
more help to people and
i actually spoke with uh meet kevin
who's
who's running for governor and i have an
interview with him live stream on his
channel
on tuesday at 2 pm pst um he's talking
to me about how we could restructure
the homelessness epidemic and mental
health epidemic
in the united states in california
specifically
and then hopefully people can mimic that
plan for other states
the key to amanda's recovery i think was
the forced
rehab yeah it was forced she didn't she
didn't have a choice of
whether she wanted to stay here exactly
because we literally pulled her rock
bottom because
if an addict is given a choice
eventually they'll have a bad day and
leave
yeah and i believe in what you say
possibilities all things are possible as
a result
of what has happened to amanda because i
believe i pray every day and believe
in my prayers and i believe that god has
helped us in this
brought her us together and he just
showed us that what we did was
all good for us no his amazing story
that amanda
recovered fully unbelievably yeah
she claimed it repeatedly yeah it was
beautiful
yeah she made sure and larry your your
strength throughout this whole week
has been incredible well on your drive
on your drive to las vegas um to go see
amanda um you saw that there was an
endless rainbow oh wow i have never seen
this and i used to take pictures around
the world of places sunset
sunrise we were traveling on the back
road
to las vegas and we had a wrap-around
rainbow
and when i saw it i'm going well okay
first we see everything in california
beautiful weather all the time
but once i kept looking and i never saw
the end of it
and i began to pray because i'm going to
prepare to see amanda
i've never seen a wraparound rainbow
before
albert kept saying you're right
you know albert he's missed a curiosity
we had nothing to say it was just
incredible and it didn't go away didn't
fade away quickly
no it was um i wrote i wrote something
down because it really stuck with me
yeah so um i was telling one of
our friends about what happened and he
kind of made like a nerdy
affiliation it was a starbucks uh star
wars quote
but it really resonated with amanda so
he said that there was a scene in star
wars where the bad guys were fighting
and where the good guy was fighting the
bad guy and the good guy
said um you can't win
even if you strike me down i will become
sorry
i will become more powerful
than you could ever imagine
and i feel like amanda's death
is gonna change the entire way that we
do things
but more importantly amanda's life
and what she proved while she was alive
um i went from planning her future to
her funeral
it's
but amanda's favorite song was it's a
wonderful world
i used to play that song when she was in
the car she just to make her keep quiet
and i would look back and she would be
just into the song
man so i would just play it again so it
turned out that she would always want me
to play
when we returned back from las vegas
there was a man
standing um we were dropping larry home
and there was a man standing outside of
larry's building with his dog
and he heard what we were talking about
amanda and i guess he had known amanda
as well
and he just said they say that god
takes you when you've served your
purpose
but i just thought that that was so
powerful and i think that
um you know we all have so much to learn
from her short life
but i'm really grateful that i met
amanda i'm really grateful that we got
to work together
and i'm really grateful that um larry is
going to continue
to work with me and build up amanda's
legacy and prove that
you know not let her die in vain but
really
use what she proved while she was alive
that anything is possible
to transform um so many lives so
we're taking down the gofundme page
because she's no longer here
um but if anyone wants to continue to
support what we're doing
with offering scholarships and trying to
make it open and accessible
to everyone you can sign the petition
and you can also donate directly on the
website it goes
to giving and we want to open up the
scholarship program to
everyone applicants once we raise enough
funding
to be able to help everybody well i
really see so clearly because i've
helped
tried to help so many people on my own
and the money ends up being wasted
because as i see it the only way that
getting someone clean off drugs is is a
program similar to what amanda had
yeah which is which was two two months
of
forced jail time formula it's either
jail or psych ward
or you can willingly go to a homeless
shelter
i used to volunteer here on skid row i
had my birthday party here on skid row
at the la mission
um i was when i first got here and i
witnessed what was going on
i thought oh my god these people
probably don't know where to find help
and when i arrived i
i realized that it's actually
skid row is just the entire block
you've got four different homeless
shelters
but the problem is when we'd be cooking
um in the
in the kitchen we would have so
much food and so little people come in
that we'd be serving seconds and thirds
and all of the people are just sitting
outside they refuse to come in and the
programs aren't
forcing you to do a program they're not
forcing you to be clean so you can
actually
come in eat and then leave
you have the second choice of coming in
eating and staying for one night but not
committing to a program and then you can
also come
in eat stay for an entire program and
then they help do job placement
and all of that other stuff and they
also offer mental health resources
i mean getting you clean off of drugs
but the problem is people will not come
in not even to eat a meal
and it's because again their brain is so
damaged you took away the prefrontal
cortex you took away their logic
and when you look at brain activity
everything
shuts down when someone's so
malnutritioned
all the lights and all the other parts
of the brain the blood flow
stops flowing it just goes to the center
and that's survival mode so the only
thing they're thinking of is drug
seeking what's going to make me feel
better right now
and they cannot plan for the future
because that's prefrontal cortex
and any sort of motivation is located in
the pleasure center so like the
right and left hemispheres of the brain
which is where all the dopamine goes
so it's like the motivation is only
there when they're high and it leaves
when they're not
so you can't expect those people to make
decisions for themselves
so something needs to change yeah
absolutely
let's hope amanda's beautiful story
isn't in vain and leaving this is not
the end this is only the beginning
yeah larry and lima thank you so much
thank you mark
thank you mark you've been a treasure
man we'll carry on
thank you thank you thank you
you